welcome to local players I'm Chris
waters your host and i'm joined by
multiple players Peter Brown Sean
McGinnis Maxwell McGee hey guys today
we're playing star wall just the tip no
I didn't make that name up it's an
actual game in which you space joust
with narwhals and try to stab each other
with the narwhal tusk alright so I'm
orange Princess Leia Narwhal Peter who
are you I'm a sour cream garhwal with a
banana my head in a burrito skirt look
nice Sean I'm the pink kitty in the
ballerina dress yeah you are Maxwell I'm
afro princess wait gotta change your
ballerina body I have these poop first i
was there i called it he did that what
you didn't call alright that's done you
guys can duel at asteroid x to see who
is triumphant here we go basically the
premise with game is you fell down just
stab you need to stab each other in
their Narwhal hearts Oh char wall murder
on the tip okay hold down a you can oh
there we go oh there we go I'm happy
face yeah oh come on yeah Oh counter
stabbed whoa can't believe an engine
stand out no yeah you don't worry oh oh
my goodness the grace the NARS elegance
oh he's out yeah why didn't I stay
bottom-dwelling Oh Cinderella's here I
can do that what is that
that we're just gonna give you a neck
pillow cake we're gonna hug it out hey
Joe there we go anything especially
witty oh I will Rita on the show it
comes from somebody who's not Bob Jill I
sleep finally I just had the analog
stick and the a button button is like
your accelerator but then you just kind
of flailing yeah it's your accelerator
Oh lose the same way 69 hold on you can
hurt your own heart I don't know if
there's a sword sticking on the ground
and you walk into it does it hurt white
10 what the hell is on your face shot
I'm feeling pretty good about this guy
from a blind to gym no no your real bad
situation huh I'm in a real bad
direction he is one of rub hearts oh no
rubbin har all man that [ __ ] oh yeah
gross rude I think I just hit three you
all in a row there we got a prehensile
rid of chipping oh oh the only real
monster tempt back you say you need not
don't II hit hospital your tip follow
your tip your tip never lies does it Oh
Michael oh not this time not this on
boys oh i watch bores get tipped oh come
on you blocked my tip in with your tip
yeah wiggle wiggle every way that one
wiggle wiggle three in a row four in a
row only took I'm giving up so many tips
tips tips and trace chicks [ __ ] open
a new tips and tricks magazine
da Tim this is bad Tim's bad you focus
on tips i needa going I need to get back
to the tip basics think about these two
oh you like that all right here we go
texan na 2 o 3 x3 Oh tips to meet you
too there's more I'm enough so many tips
just go me show that way down oh wow
that was a cross the street yeah oh yeah
fire alarm hipster yeah twitch chat
reacting to all did all right Matt Smith
83 says stop dipping your tip okay no
opportunity says don't stick your tip
and crazy content so that's just life
advice yeah toaster says reach around
for the win there's no reach around
button in Star Wars far as I know me
let's just mash on our xbox
compelling
the beautiful song misinformation
guys I'm ready I'm he raise your dongers
are they slow down is when when your
lighter gets tips it's like you go Peter
I me right this is to midori 000000
maximal barely has got vengeance don't
stop tivity oh you were asking for that
tip boom eat it burrito guy no I got you
yeah oh my heart let's come up here and
tip it up oh oh oh just the one tip
thank you very much just one and done
wham bam thank you tip over Timmy
longstockings whoo tip upon soggy even
way to say them oh yeah but put the
power tint ah no no no second this
you're a cow oh oh I have nine points
ooh who's gonna win it's gonna be Shawn
oh gosh we get in on this let me check
this oh you got T blocks no huh the tip
flip wait Fredo you already in that tip
tip why are you blocking my teeth
extraction watch it on the tip yeah Wow
lunch time that was weak Brock come on
get tips no I got to know if it is a
chef Peter where's your mom
oh yeah keep carrying a metaphor why are
you matching for maximum confusion yeah
here we go this is [ __ ] no wiggle we
are you like that I'm knock in with my
chip yeah oh you wants to go on back
darlin we're little lady oh not today
Jonah real pretty bow oh thank you wow
you have a monocle oh yeah cuz I'm a
gentleman hot dog what do you take me
for some kind of guy who's not a GD
gentleman hot dog oh sit for gentlemen
do lunch raise your dongers it's a hoot
ha i even get any more raised right now
right it's no fair there's balls that
are colored like you guys but not like
us oh that doesn't matter doesn't matter
I just kicked the [ __ ] out of you watch
him ok kid 20 like a rare icons here
yeah yeah tipped up to take that to be
here I'm coming to help get in there Oh
me again G true lumberjacks I'll hide in
the ball pit but they won't find it what
is where D to go it's somewhere in the
pumpkin I can smell his tip
and escape whoa whoa yeah the old hiding
tip acrobatics I way nope no I'm
wikitree this trading tips your tip is
mine oh my goodness what you know about
to maxwell's what we're doing I'm hired
to help what is it 1040 took him of
course the same thing have you said
about all tips so anyway have that tip I
am playing as Jordi Jordi letip over
here I'm orange Peter mortgage loans are
you back to lunch food come on man let's
argue back and Max really you're not a
fro princess all right sean as a fellow
costume innovator I can took what
describe to us what you like a fish man
tip man rocked him rot I rock to have a
feeling you're definitely in Japan i'm
known as rock tip your tip is really big
into fitted hahaha don't you think that
won't understand it in it under Titov
all day no oh nuts I was trying to come
around from the wrist of hot tip on tip
action here's a tip get to tip of the
morning to you BAM like that flag Oh
double towel around limit not owed oh
[ __ ] damn whoa this is you could cut the
tension with a knife or a tip cord you
can tip the tension with the tip oh no
no hero team-up princess gets it oh oh
yeah you hit me from behind yeah there's
no tipping flag on hires for tilt we
have a gentleman's agreement you can't
sneak tip me from behind
oh you got off in the back flip you got
sloppy and I'm glad for the tracks well
down to one heart as afro ballerina
Sean's Tron tip is it away from me don't
miss me Owen any other sir I'll tip you
always exposed who can max will score
the tip he needs ah get the equalizer
whoa keepo is a time I met her yet na i
had that oh I so maybe we need a choice
we need a judge on this table over here
I had that match what what are you
thinking about Kim sean i think this
game is a fun game to play with people
mostly because of the tip jokes you're
in the sweat and the sweat any intent
sweat it's real hot real hot right
you